you may remember a Kyle Rittenhouse and
Kyle Rittenhouse during the the Kenosha
Summer of Love Riot the administration
was calling him a white supremacist with
absolutely no evidence the president of
the United States
called Kyle Rittenhouse a white
supremacist here's Peter Ducey asking
Jen saki we haven't shown Jen's sake in
a while here's a throwback sake drink if
you got a little something with you why
did President Biden suggest that Kyle
Rittenhouse on trial in Kenosha is a
white supremacist
so Peter what I I'm not going to speak
to right now is anything about an
ongoing trial uh nor the president's
past comments uh what I can reiterate
for you is the president's of you uh
that we shouldn't have broadly speaking
of Vigilantes patrolling our communities
with assault weapons we shouldn't have
opportunist corrupting peaceful protests
by rioting and burning down the
communities they claim to represent so
Kyle Rittenhouse I'm told now has 24 7
security with him I've met him once or
twice at different events seems like a
really decent kid not not a white
supremacist as far as I can tell there
was no evidence by the way that he was a
white supremacist now you could say okay
he didn't do the right thing or he did
do the right thing or whatever shouldn't
be out there blah blah blah that's all
separate the president of the United
States with no evidence called this kid
a white supremacist and Saki knew it
right there which is why she's not going
to get into it but this rhetoric
actually does lead to violence and leads
to the destruction of lives you know we
referenced this a couple days ago but
you may remember about a year ago here's
a quote from Fox News this one involves
me because I'm trying to show you guys
how they do it to everybody liberal New
York Times editorial board member Mara
gay was roasted Tuesday for claiming in
an interview that commentator Dave Rubin
regularly hosts white supremacists on
his show the Reuben report although in
fact she called it the Dave Rubin show
gay a frequent critic a Critic of
conservatives and Republicans on MSNBC
made the claim during a newspaper's
editorial endorsement interview with
Democratic City mayoral candidate Andrew
Yang in which she also incorrectly
labeled the show at the David show okay
fine over the years you've built your
brand by frequently doing radio and
other appearances with right wing media
personalities at times you've said the
Democratic party should gravitate away
from Identity politics you've supported
automated fast food workers at times why
appear on shows like the Dave Rubin show
who regularly hosts white supremacists
gay ass Yang in the interview okay
doesn't matter about me I really mean
that but I'm trying to show you this is
what they do with everyone and that's
the point the point is not about the
specific thing the point is about the
signal right it is the signal that they
try to send to everybody else okay and
and more broadly they never help
minorities they try to make it seem like
there's this whole group of people that
are out there attacking minorities all
the time because they aren't obsessed
with minorities right they believe in
individual rights okay so because
they're not obsessed obsessively
pandering to these communities that
means you don't care about them instead
the left just puts in policies that
actually harm their lives